Bien, c'est super d'être ici.
Nous avons entendu beaucoup de choses sur les promesses de la technologie, et leur danger.
Les deux aspects m'ont vraiment intéressé.
Si nous pouvions convertir 0,03%
de la lumière du soleil qui tombe sur la terre en énergie,
nous pourrions satisfaire tous nos besoins prévus pour 2030.
Nous ne pouvons pas le faire aujourd'hui parce que les panneaux solaires sont lourds,
chers et très inefficaces.
Il y a des conceptions nano-technologiques,
qui ont été analysées au moins théoriquement,
qui montrent qu'elles sont potentiellement très légères
très peu coûteuses, très efficaces,
et nous pourrions satisfaire réellement tous nos besoins énergétiques de cette façon renouvelable.
Les piles à combustible nano-technologiques
pourraient fournir l'énergie là où elle nécessaire.
C'est une tendance principale, qui est la décentralisation,
de passer de centrales nucléaires centralisées et
des bateaux-citernes de gaz naturel liquide
à des ressources décentralisées qui sont plus respectueuses de l'environnement,
beaucoup plus efficaces
et capable et de manière stable.
Bono dit avec éloquence,
que nous avons les outils, pour la première fois,
pour aborder les problèmes ancestraux de la maladie et de la pauvreté.
La plupart des régions du monde vont dans cette direction.
En 1990, en Asie de l'Est et dans le Pacifique,
il y avait 500 millions de personnes qui vivaient dans la pauvreté --
ce chiffre est maintenant en dessous de 200 millions.
La Banque Mondiale prévoit que d'ici 2011, il sera en dessous de 20 millions,
ce qui représente une réduction de 95 pour cent.
J'ai apprécié le commentaire de Bono
qui faisait le lien entre Haight-Ashbury et la Silicon Valley.
Faisant moi-même partie de la communauté high-tech du Massachusetts
je préciserais que nous étions des hippies également dans les années 1960,
même si on traînait autour de Harvard Square.
Mais nous avons le potentiel de surmonter la maladie et la pauvreté,
si nous en avons la volonté et je vais parler de ces questions.
Kevin Kelly a parlé de l'accélération de la technologie.
Cela m'intéresse énormément,
et c'est un thème que j'ai développé pendant environ 30 ans.
Je me suis rendu compte que mes technologies devaient avoir du sens une fois le projet terminé.
Qu'invariablement, le monde serait différent
quand j'introduirai une technologie.
Et, j'ai remarqué que la plupart des inventions échouent,
pas parce que le département R&D ne peut pas les faire fonctionner --
si vous regardez la plupart des projets commerciaux, ils réussiront vraiment
si l'occasion est donnée de construire ce qu'ils disent qu'ils vont construire,
et 90% de ces projets ou plus échoueront, parce que ce n'est pas le bon moment --
tous les facteurs favorables ne seront pas là quand on en aura besoin.
J'ai donc commencé à étudier de près les tendances des technologies,
et chercher où en serait la technologie à différents points dans le temps,
et j'ai commencé à en faire des modèles mathématiques..
C'est devenu un projet en lui-même.
J'ai un groupe de 10 personnes qui travaillent avec moi pour recueillir des données
sur des indicateurs des niveaux de technologie dans de nombreux secteurs, et nous construisons des modèles.
Et vous entendrez les gens dire, et bien, nous ne pouvons pas prédire l'avenir.
Et si vous me posez la question,
le prix de Google sera-t-il plus élevé ou plus bas que ce qu'il est aujourd'hui, d'ici trois ans,
c'est très difficile à dire.
WiMax CDMA 3G
sera-t-elle la norme sans fil d'ici trois ans ? C'est difficile à dire.
Mais si vous me demandez, ce que coûtera
un MIPS de calcul en 2010,
ou le séquençage d'une paire de base d'ADN en 2012,
ou l'envoi sans fil d'un mégabit de données en 2014,
il s'avère que ces choses-là sont très prévisibles.
Il y a les courbes exponentielles remarquablement lisses
qui régissent coût-performances, capacité, bande passante.
Et je vais vous montrer un petit échantillon de ceci,
mais il y a vraiment une raison théorique
pour laquelle la technologie se développe de façon exponentielle.
Et beaucoup de gens, quand ils pensent à l'avenir, y pensent linéairement.
Ils pensent qu'ils vont continuer
à développer un problème
ou à aborder un problème en utilisant les outils d'aujourd'hui,
au rythme du progrès d'aujourd'hui,
et ne prendrons pas en compte cette croissance exponentielle.
Le projet de génome était un projet controversé en 1990.
Nous avions les meilleurs doctorants
l'équipement le plus avancé du monde,
nous avions fait le dix-millième du projet ,
et comment allons-nous faire ça en 15 ans ?
Et 10 ans après,
les sceptiques étaient toujours aussi insistants -- ils disaient, "vous êtes au deux-tiers de ce projet,
et vous avez seulement séquencé
un pourcentage très minuscule du génome entier."
Mais c'est la nature de la croissance exponentielle
qui une fois qu'elle atteint le sommet de la courbe, explose.
La majeure partie du projet a été faite pendant
les dernières années du projet.
Cela nous a pris 15 ans pour séquencer le VIH--
nous avons séquencé le SRAS en 31 jours.
Nous sommes donc en train d'acquérir le potentiel de surmonter ces problèmes.
Je vais juste vous montrer quelques exemples
de l'omniprésence de ce phénomène.
Le taux réel de changement de paradigme, le taux d'adoption de nouvelles idées,
double chaque décennie, selon nos modèles.
Ce sont tous les graphiques logarithmiques,
donc plus vous progressez, les niveaux se multiplient, en général par des facteurs de 10 ou 100.
Il nous a fallu un demi-siècle pour adopter le téléphone,
la première technologie de réalité virtuelle.
Les téléphones portables ont été adoptés en huit ans environ .
Si vous mettiez différentes technologies des communications
sur ce graphique logarithmique,
télévision, radio, téléphone
ont été adopté en quelques décennies.
Les technologies récentes -- comme le PC, le Web, les téléphones portables --
en moins d'une décennie.
Maintenant c'est un diagramme intéressant,
et il touche vraiment la raison fondamentale pour laquelle
les processus évolutifs -- et la biologie et la technologie sont des processus évolutifs --
s'accélèrent.
Ils fonctionnent par interaction -- ils créent une capacité,
puis emploient cette capacité pour passer à l'étape suivante.
Ainsi la première étape dans l'évolution biologique,
l'évolution de l'ADN -- en fait c'est ARN qui est venu en premier --
a pris des milliards d'années,
mais ensuite l'évolution a utilisé cette épine dorsale de traitement de l'information
pour passer à l'étape suivante.
Ainsi l'explosion cambrienne, pendant laquelle tous les plans des corps des animaux étaient finalisés,
a pris seulement 10 millions d'années. Ce fut 200 fois plus rapide.
Et puis l'évolution a employé ces plans
pour développer des fonctions cognitives avancées,
et l'évolution biologique a continué son accélération.
C'est une nature inhérente d'un processus évolutif.
Ainsi homo sapiens,la première espèce qui crée de la technologie,
l'espèce qui combine une fonction cognitive
avec un appendice opposable --
et au fait, les chimpanzés n'ont pas vraiment un très bon pouce opposable --
pour que nous puissions vraiment manipuler notre environnement fermement
et une coordination moteur précise,
et employons nos modèles mentaux pour changer réellement le monde
et faire progresser la technologie.
Mais bon, l'évolution de notre espèce a pris des centaines de milliers d'années,
et puis en travaillant par interaction,
l'évolution a utilisé, essentiellement,
l'espèce qui créait des technologies pour passer à l'étape suivante,
et ça a été les premiers pas dans l'évolution technologique.
Et le premier pas a pris des dizaines de milliers d'années --
les outils en pierre, le feu, la roue -- l'accélération s'est poursuivie.
Nous avons alors toujours employé la dernière génération de la technologie
pour créer la génération suivante.
Il a fallu un siècle pour adopter l'imprimerie,
les premiers ordinateurs étaient conçus sur papier -- maintenant nous utilisons des ordinateurs.
Et nous avons eu une accélération continuelle de ce processus.
D'ailleurs, si vous regardez ceci sur un graphique linéaire, on dirait que tout vient à peine de se produire.
mais un observateur dit, "bien, Kurzweil s'appuie sur ce graphique
où des points suivent cette ligne droite."
Donc, j'ai pris 15 listes différentes chez des principaux penseurs ,
comme l'encyclopédie Britannica, le musée d'histoire naturelle, le calendrier cosmique de Carl Sagan
sur la même chose -- et ces personnes n'essayaient pas confirmer mon propos,
c'était juste des listes dans des travaux de référence.
Et je pense que c'est ce qu'ils considéraient comme des événements principaux
dans l'évolution biologique et l'évolution technologique.
Là encore, on obtient la même ligne droite. La ligne s'épaissit un peu
parce que les gens ne sont pas tous d'accord sur les points les points clés,
il y a des divergences d'opinion sur quand l'agriculture est apparue,
ou quand -- combien de temps l'explosion cambrienne a duré.
Mais vous voyez une tendance très claire.
Il y a une accélération de base et profonde de ce processus évolutif.
Les technologies de l'information doublent leur capacité, coût-performances, bande passante,
chaque année.
Et c'est une explosion très profonde de croissance exponentielle.
Une expérience personnelle, quand j'étais au MIT --
l' ordinateur avait en gros la taille de cette salle,
moins puissant que l'ordinateur dans votre téléphone portable.
Mais la loi de Moore, qui est très souvent identifiée à cette croissance exponentielle,
est juste un exemple parmi d'autres, parce que c'est fondamentalement
une propriété du processus évolutif de la technologie.
Si nous -- j'ai mis 49 ordinateurs célèbres sur ce graphique logarithmique --
d'ailleurs, une ligne droite sur un graphique logarithmique, c'est une croissance exponentielle --
c'est un autre exponentiel.
Cela nous a pris trois ans pour doubler notre coût-performances de calcul en 1900,
deux ans au milieu, nous le doublons maintenant chaque année.
Et c'est la croissance exponentielle à travers cinq paradigmes différents.
La loi de Moore était juste la dernière partie de cela,
sur un circuit intégré, où nous réduisions les transistors,
mais nous avions des calculatrices électromécaniques,
des ordinateurs basés sur relais qui ont décodé le code allemand d'Enigma,
les tubes à vide dans les années 1950 ont prévu l'élection d'Eisenhower,
les transistors discrets utilisés dans les premiers vols spatiaux
et puis la loi de Moore.
Chaque fois qu'un paradigme s'est essoufflé,
un autre paradigme est venu par la bande pour continuer la croissance exponentielle.
Ils rétrécissaient des tubes à vide, les rendant de plus en plus petits.
Cela a rencontré un mur. Ils ne pourraient pas les rétrécir et garder le vide.
Un paradigme totalement différent -- les transistors étaient partout.
En fait, quand nous arrivons au bout d'un paradigme particulier,
ça crée la pression sur la recherche pour créer le paradigme suivant.
Et parce que nous avons prévu la fin de la loi de Moore
depuis un bon moment -- d'abord on prévoyait en 2002, et maintenant on dit en 2022.
Mais d'ici les années 2013 à 2020,
les transistors n'auront que quelques atomes de largeur,
et nous ne pourrons pas les rétrécir plus.
Ce sera la fin de la loi de Moore, mais ce ne sera pas la fin de
la croissance exponentielle du calcul, parce que les puces sont plates.
Nous vivons dans un monde tridimensionnel, nous pourrions aussi bien utiliser la troisième dimension.
Nous entrerons dans la troisième dimension
et c'a été un progrès énorme, juste pendant ces dernières années,
de faire fonctionner des circuits moléculaires à organisation autonome tridimensionnels.
Nous les aurons mis au point bien avant que la loi de Moore ne s'épuise.
Les superordinateurs -- même chose.
La performance d'un processeur sur des puces d'Intel,
le prix moyen d'un transistor --
1968, vous pouviez acheter un transistor pour un dollar.
Vous pouviez en acheter 10 millions en 2002.
Il est assez remarquable combien
ce processus exponentiel est lisse.
Je veux dire, vous pourriez penser que c'est le résultat d'une expérience de simulation,
mais c'est le résultat du comportement chaotique mondial --
Les pays qui s'accusent mutuellement de faire du dumping sur des produits,
les introductions en bourse, les faillites, les programmes de commercialisation.
Vous pourriez penser que ce serait un processus très erratique,
et vous avez des résultats
lisses de ce processus chaotique.
Tout comme nous ne pouvons pas prévoir
ce qu'une molécule dans un gaz fera --
il est impossible de prédire une simple molécule --
pourtant nous pouvons prévoir les propriétés du gaz entier,
en utilisant la thermodynamique,de façon très précise.
C'est la même chose ici. Nous ne pouvons pas faire de prévisions sur un projet particulier,
mais le résultat de cette compétition
imprévisible, chaotique, et mondiale,
et le processus évolutif de la technologie est très prévisible.
Et nous pouvons prévoir ces tendances loin dans l'avenir.
À la différence des roses de Gertrude Stein,
on ne peut pas dire qu'un transistor est un transistor.
Comme nous les rendons plus petits et moins chers,
les électrons ont moins de distance à parcourir.
Ils sont plus rapides, donc vous avez une croissance exponentielle de la vitesse des transistors,
donc le coût d'un cycle d'un transistor
a été diminué par deux tous les 1,1 ans.
Vous ajoutez d'autres formes d'innovation et de conception de processeur,
vous obtenez un doublement de coût-performances de calcul chaque année.
Et c'est en fait une déflation --
50% de déflation.
Et ce n'est pas seulement les ordinateurs. Je veux dire, c'est vrai pour le séquençage de l'ADN,
c'est vrai pour le scanner du cerveau,
c'est vrai pour le Web. Je veux dire, tout ce que nous pouvons mesurer,
nous avons des centaines de mesures différentes
de mesures relatives à l'information différentes --
capacité, taux d'adoption --
et elles doublent en fait tous les 12, 13, 15 mois,
selon ce que vous regardez.
En termes de coût-performances, ce sont des taux de déflation de 40 à 50%.
Et les économistes ont réellement commencé à s'en inquiéter.
Nous avons eu une déflation pendant la grande dépression,
mais c'était l'effondrement de la masse monétaire,
l'effondrement de confiance du consommateur, des phénomènes complètement différents.
Ceci est dû à une plus grande productivité,
mais l'économiste dit, "mais on ne peut absolument pas continuer comme ça.
Si vous avez 50% de déflation, les gens peuvent augmenter leur volume
de 30, 40% , mais ils ne pourront pas suivre.
Mais en fait ce que nous voyons c'est que
nous arrivons largement à suivre.
Nous avons eu une croissance en dollars de 28% par an
en technologie de l'information au cours des 50 dernières années.
Je veux dire, les gens n'auraient pas fabriqué l'iPod pour 10 000 dollars il y a 10 ans.
Comme le coût-performances rend possible de nouvelles apllications,
de nouvelles applications arrivent sur le marché.
Et c'est un phénomène très répandu.
Le stockage de données magnétiques --
ce n'est pas la loi de Moore, il s'agit de rétrécir des points magnétiques,
différents ingénieurs, différentes sociétés, le même processus exponentiel.
Une révolution principale c'est que nous comprenons notre propre biologie
dans ces termes d'information.
Nous comprenons les logiciels
qui font fonctionner notre corps.
Ceux-ci ont évolués à des périodes très différentes --
nous voudrions vraiment changer ces programmes.
Un petit logiciel, appelé le gène de récepteur d'insuline,
dit en fait, "Garde chaque calorie,
parce que la saison de chasse suivante pourrait être moins bonne."
C'était dans l'intérêt de des espèces, il y a des dizaines de milliers d'années.
Nous voudrions vraiment arrêter ce programme.
On a essayé chez les animaux, et ces souris ont mangé voracement
et sont restées minces et ont profité des avantages de santé d'être mince.
Elles n'ont pas eu de diabète, elles n'ont pas eu de maladie cardiaque,
elles ont vécu 20% plus longtemps, elles ont obtenu les avantages de santé de la restriction calorique
sans restriction.
Quatre ou cinq entreprises pharmaceutiques l'ont remarqué ,
ont senti que ce serait
un médicament intéressant pour le marché humain,
et ce n'est qu'un des 30,000 gènes
qui affectent notre biochimie.
Notre évolution s'est faite dans une ère où ce n'était pas dans l'intérêt des gens
à l'âge de la plupart des personnes présentes à cette conférence, comme moi,
de vivre beaucoup plus longtemps, parce que nous épuisions les ressources précieuses
qu'il valait mieux déployer vers les enfants
et ceux qui s'occupaient d'eux.
Donc, la vie -- les longues durées de vie --
comme, c'est-à-dire, bien au delà de 30 ans --
n'étaient pas sélectionnées
mais nous apprenons à manipuler
et changer ces logiciels pour de bon
par la révolution biotechnologique.
Par exemple, nous pouvons maintenant inhiber des gènes avec l'interférence d'ARN.
Il y a de nouvelles formes intéressantes de thérapie génique
qui surmontent le problème de placer le matériel génétique
au bon endroit sur le chromosome.
Il y a réellement -- pour la première fois aujourd'hui,
quelque chose qui en est au stade de passer aux essais humains, qui traite réellement l'hypertension pulmonaire --
une maladie mortelle -- en utilisant la thérapie génique.
Ainsi nous n'aurons pas que des bébés sur mesure, mais des baby boomers sur mesure.
Et cette technologie s'accélère aussi.
10 dollars par paires de base en 1990,
puis un cent en 2000.
Maintenant c'est moins d'un dixième de cent.
La quantité de données génétiques --
montre en fait que cette croissance exponentielle lisse
a doublé chaque année,
permettant de mener à terme le projet de génome.
Une autre révolution majeure, la révolution des communications.
Le coût-performances, la bande passante, la capacité de communications ont été mesuré de nombreuses façons différentes ;
le cable, le sans-fil se développent exponentiellement.
L'Internet avait doublé en puissance et il continue ,
on le mesure de nombreuses façons différentes.
Ceci est basé sur le nombre d'ordinateurs hôtes.
La miniaturisation -- nous rétrécissons la taille de la technologie
à un taux exponentiel,
à la fois pour le cable et le sans-fil.
Ce sont quelques conceptions tirées du livre d'Éric Drexler --
dont nous montrons maintenant qu'elles sont faisables
avec des simulations de superinformatique,
où en fait il y a des scientifiques qui construisent
des robots à l'échelle de la molécule.
Dans l'une d'elles il y en a un qui marche vraiment avec une démarche étonnamment humaine,
et il est construit à partir de molécules.
Il y a de petites machines qui font des choses sur des bases expérimentales.
L'opportunité la plus passionnante
est en fait d'aller à l'intérieur du corps humain
et de remplir des fonctions thérapeutiques et diagnostiques.
Et c'est moins futuriste qu'il n'y parait.
On l'a déjà fait chez les animaux.
Il y a un dispositif nano-technologique qui traite le diabète de type 1. Il a la taille d'une cellule.
Ils en ont mis des dizaines de milliers
dans le globule -- ils l'ont essayé chez les rats --
il libère l'insuline de façon contrôlée,
et traite réellement le diabète de type 1.
Ce que vous observez est une conception
d'un globule rouge robotique,
et cela soulève le problème que notre biologie
est vraiment très suboptimale,
bien qu'elle soit remarquable dans sa complexité.
Une fois que nous comprenons ses principes de fonctionnement,
et que la vitesse à laquelle nous rétro-concevons la biologiqe s'accélère,
nous pouvons en fait concevoir ces choses pour qu'elles soient
des milliers de fois plus capables.
Une analyse de ce respirocyte, conçu par Rob Freitas,
indique que si vous remplacez 10 % de vos globules rouges par ces versions robotiques,
vous pourriez faire un sprint olympique pendant 15 minutes sans reprendre votre respiration.
Vous pourriez vous asseoir au fond de votre piscine pendant quatre heures --
-- ainsi, "Ma chérie, je suis dans la piscine," prendrait une toute nouvelle signification.
Il sera intéressant de voir ce que nous faisons dans nos épreuves olympiques.
Vraisemblablement nous les interdirons,
mais alors nous aurons le spectre des adolescents dans leurs gymnases de lycées
qui régulièrement dépasseraient les performances des athlètes olympiques.
Freitas a une conception pour un globule blanc robotique.
Ce sont des scénarios pour les années 2020,
mais ils ne sont pas aussi futuristes qu'il y parait.
Il y a quatre conférences importantes sur la construction d'appareils à l'échelle du globule rouge,
il y a beaucoup d'expériences chez les animaux.
Il y en a en fait une en cours sur l'homme,
donc c'est technologiquement faisable.
Si nous revenons à notre croissance exponentielle du calcul,
1,000 dollars de calcul est maintenant quelque part entre un insecte et un cerveau de souris.
Elle croisera l'intelligence humaine
en termes de capacité dans les années 2020,
mais ce sera le côté matériel de l'équation.
D'où obtiendrons-nous le logiciel ?
Et bien, il s'avère que nous pouvons regarder à l'intérieur de l'esprit humain,
et en fait comme on pouvait s'y attendre,
la résolution spatiale et temporelle du scanner du cerveau double chaque année.
Et avec la nouvelle génération des outils de scanographie du cerveau
pour la première fois nous pouvons réellement voir
différentes fibres intra-neurales
et les voir traiter l'information et signaler en temps réel
et -- mais alors la question est, bon, on peut obtenir ces données maintenant,
mais pouvons-nous les comprendre ?
Doug Hofstadter se demande, et bien, peut-être que notre intelligence
n'est simplement pas suffisante pour comprendre notre intelligence,
et si nous étions plus intelligents, et bien, puis nos cerveaux seraient beaucoup plus compliqués que ça,
et nous n'y arriverions jamais.
Il s'avère que nous pouvons le comprendre.
Ceci est un schéma fonctionnel
d'un modèle et d'une simulation du cortex auditif humain
qui fonctionne en fait assez bien --
en appliquant les tests psychoacoustiques, on obtient des résultats très similaires à la perception auditive humaine.
Il y a une autre simulation du cervelet --
c'est plus de la moitié des neurones dans le cerveau --
là encore, qui travaille de façon très similaire à la formation de compétence humaine.
Ceci est au tout début, mais vous pouvez montrer
avec la croissance exponentielle de la quantité d'informations sur le cerveau
et l'amélioration exponentielle
de la résolution du balayage de cerveau,
que nous réussirons à rétro-convecoir l'esprit humain
d'ici les années 2020.
Nous avons déjà eu de très bons modèles et une simulation d'environ 15 régions
sur plusieurs centaines.
Tout cela est exponentiel --
un progrès économique exponentiel-croissant.
Nous avons fait aller la productivité de 30 dollars à 150 dollars par heure
de travail pendant les 50 dernières années.
Le commerce électronique s'est développé exponentiellement. C'est maintenant un trillion de dollars.
Vous pourriez vous demander, et bien, n'avons-nous pas eu un boom et un fiasco?
C'était strictement des phénomènes de marchés financiers.
Wall Street a remarqué que c'était une technologie révolutionnaire, et ça l'est,
mais ensuite six mois plus tard, quand ça n'a pas révolutionné tous les modèles économiques,
ils ont pensé, bien, que c'était faux,
et alors nous avons eu ce fiasco.
Bien, c'est une technologie
que nous nous assemblons en utilisant certaines des technologies dans lesquelles nous sommes impliqués.
Ce sera une caractéristique courante dans un téléphone portable.
Il pourrait traduire d'une langue à l'autre.
Laissez-ainsi moi juste finir avec deux ou trois scénarios.
D'ici 2010 les ordinateurs disparaîtront.
Ils seront si petits, ils seront intégrés dans nos vêtements, dans notre environnement.
Des images seront écrites directement sur notre rétine,
fournissant la réalité virtuelle en totale immersion,
une vraie réalité augmentée. Nous interagirons avec des personnalités virtuelles.
Mais si nous allons à 2029, nous avons vraiment la pleine maturité de ces tendances,
et vous devez prendre en copmte combien de tours de vis donnés de plus en plus vite
nous aurons à ce moment là en termes de générations de technologie.
Je veux dire, nous aurons un coût-performances
une capacité et une bande passante multiplié par deux à la puissance 25
de ces technologies, ce qui est assez phénoménal.
Ce sera des millions de fois plus puissant qu'aujourd'hui.
Nous aurons accompli la rétro-conception de l'esprit humain,
calcul -- 1,000 dollars de calcul seront bien plus puissants
que l'esprit humain en termes de capacité brute de base.
Les ordinateurs combineront
les puissances subtiles de pan-reconnaissance
de l'intelligence humaine avec les manières pour les machines sont déjà supérieures,
en termes de pensée analytique,
en retenant des milliards de faits avec précision.
Les machines peuvent partager leur connaissance très rapidement,
Mais ce n'est pas simplement une invasion étrangère des machines intelligentes.
Nous allons fusionner avec notre technologie.
Ces nano-robots que j'ai mentionnés
seront d'abord employés pour des applications médicales et de santé:
nettoyer l'environnement, fournir le carburant -- des piles à combustible puissantes
et panneaux solaires décentralisés largement distribués et ainsi de suite dans l'environnement.
Mais ils iront également à l'intérieur de notre cerveau,
et interagiront avec nos neurones biologiques.
Nous avons démontré les principes clés de notre capacité à le faire.
Donc, par exemple,
la réalité virtuelle en immersion totale à l'intérieur même du système nerveux,
les nano-robots arrêtent les signaux venant de vos vrais sens,
les remplacent par les signaux que votre cerveau recevrait
si vous étiez dans l'environnement virtuel,
Et alors vous aurez l'impression d'être dans cet environnement virtuel.
Vous pourrez y aller avec d'autres personnes, vivre toute sorte d'expérience
avec n'importe qui, en utilisant vos sens.
"Les projecteurs d' expérience ," comme je les appelle, mettront tout leur flot d'expériences sensorielles
dans les corrélations neurologiques de leurs émotions sur l'Internet.
Vous pourrez vous connecter et éprouver ce que c'est que d'être quelqu'un d'autre.
Mais avant tout,
ce sera une expansion énorme
de l'intelligence humaine par cette fusion directe avec notre technologie,
ce que dans un certain sens nous faisons déjà.
Nous faisons par habitude des exploits intellectuels
qui serait impossible sans notre technologie.
L'espérance de vie humaine s'allonge. Elle était de 37 ans en 1800,
et avec cette sorte de biotechnologie, les révolutions de nanotechnologie,
elle augmentera très rapidement
dans les années à venir.
L'essentiel de mon message est que ce progrès en technologie
est exponentiel, pas linéaire.
Beaucoup -- même les scientifiques -- adopent un modèle linéaire,
donc ils diront, "oh, il faudra des centaines d'années
avant que nous ayons auto-reproduit l'assemblage par la nanotechnologie
ou l'intelligence artificielle."
Si vous regardez vraiment la puissance de la croissance exponentielle,
vous verrez que ces choses seront bientôt là.
Et la technologie de l'information englobe de plus en plus
toutes nos vies, de notre musique à notre fabrication
à notre biologie à notre énergie aux matériaux.
Nous pourrons fabriquer presque tout ce dont nous avons besoin dans les années 2020,
à partir d'informations, dans des matières premières très peu coûteuses,
en utilisant la nanotechnologie.
Ce sont des technologies très puissantes.
Elles sont tout autant une promesse qu'un péril.
Nous devons donc avoir la volonté de les appliquer aux bons problèmes.
Merci beaucoup
(Applaudissements)